We hope you’re ready, folks, because today
we’re discussing the most dangerous SCP
of all time.
We know you’ve probably heard this before,
but seriously, this one is the absolute top
of the pyramid of fear.
Or the Fear-amid, if you will.
This SCP makes 682 weep in terror for its
life.
It makes the Old Man, SCP-106, consider turning
his life around and taking up a career in
humanitarian work.
It even makes the dreaded Scarlet King himself,
the Lord of Chaos, the Ultimate Despair, quake
in his spiky, red boots.
It’s just that utterly terrifying.
Just kidding, it’s Lego!
But we had you going there for a second, didn’t
we?
Though it may not actually be the scariest
anomaly of all time, SCP-387 isn’t your
grandad’s Lego set, either.
Unless your grandad goes by Agent Hardy, and
works for the SCP Foundation.
Hardy is one of the hundreds of thousands
of Foundation field agents planted all over
the globe, in everything from law enforcement
to surveillance, ever watchful for the kinds
of anomalies the SCP Foundation makes it their
mission to secure, contain, and protect.
But when he discovered SCP-387, he wasn’t
even technically on duty.
He was taking a long train journey home from
his parents’ house while his car was in
the shop, and as anyone who’s ever taken
a long train journey knows, without the proper
stimulation, boredom will crop up in no time.
He’d been reading a pretty interesting book
on his e-reader, when tragedy first struck,
and it ran out of battery.
Hardy had forgotten to bring his charging
cable, so he was potentially looking at another
three hours of mind-numbing monotony.
That’s when he noticed the red plastic tub
that had been apparently abandoned in the
seat across from him.
He realized in that moment that it’d been
there the whole time, unsupervised.
Given that he was a Foundation field agent,
and was, as such, extremely curious, he grabbed
the tub and took a look inside, hoping to
find something that’d quell his growing
boredom.
Lucky for him, the box was full of Lego bricks,
everyone’s favorite brand of toy construction
block.
The tub was brimming with a vast collection
of pieces, some of which - like wheels and
prisms - Agent Hardy had never seen before,
despite spending his childhood obsessively
making Lego constructions.
But Hardy wasn’t one to criticize a gift
from the universe - this tub of Lego pieces
would be the perfect way to keep himself entertained
for the rest of his long journey.
He spent the next hour or so meticulously
re-creating Site-19 in Lego form on the table
in front of him.
When the building was done, he decided to
have some fun and populate the Site with a
collection of Legomen, standing in for SCP
Foundation scientists, containment specialists,
and guards.
After finding a torso with a lab coat in the
box, Agent Hardy decided to make a tiny Dr.
Bright to start with.
However, as soon as he’d made the tiny Lego
scientist and set it down on his new Site-19
playset, he realized that everything was not
as innocently typical as it seemed : The little
man instantly began to walk, immediately picking
up a tiny Lego clipboard and heading towards
the Euclid containment wing.
Agent Hardy had discovered a brand new anomaly
on his day off while playing with toys on
a boring train ride.
Philosopher L.P. Jacks was certainly right
when he said, “A master in the art of living
draws no sharp distinction between his work
and his play.”
Naturally, Agent Hardy immediately took the
little Legoman apart, along with his Site-19
simulacrum, and alerted his superiors at the
SCP Foundation.
His coworkers met him at the next train stop
platform.
Not long after, the box of seemingly living
Lego pieces, redesignated SCP-387, was in
the hands of Foundation researcher Dr. Arch.
His first priority was finding out what exactly
they were all dealing with here, whether there
was more of it out there, and whether it was
dangerous.
Attempts to investigate the origins of SCP-387
were mostly fruitless.
Undercover Foundation agents investigated
every Lego-producing location they could find,
but found no evidence of anything similar
to 387 being produced.
And of course, as with anything that seemed
to be an anomalous toy, all possible links
to Dr. Wondertainment were also explored.
But again nothing came up.
This was probably for the best - if 387 was
a Dr. Wondertainment product, it probably
would have built itself into an actual-size
dinosaur and started eating people already.
All further investigations into 387’s origins
were subsequently dropped.
With background research turning out to be
a dead end, Dr. Arch decided to get down to
business doing the fun part: Actual experimentation.
After gathering all the proper permissions
from his superiors, the testing commenced.
In Experiment 387-a, Dr. Arch recruited a
number of Lego-loving D-Classes - after all,
even convicted robbers, arsonists, and murderers
love Lego - and made them construct a little
Lego community inside a testing chamber.
This consisted of a small main street with
a number of Lego stores, a residential area,
and a bar.
As soon as the D-Classes constructed a variety
of little Legomen and released them into the
community, they instantly came to life and
began performing their roles perfectly.
Some took up jobs in the various stores, cafes,
and boutiques, Others acted as patrons for
the different businesses.
The Legomen were even noted as forming rudimentary
family units.
One man did fall into a river in this Lego
City, but otherwise, things were going smoothly.
Encouraged by these developments, Dr. Arch
was ready to begin the true experiment: Introducing
a complex new variable into the environment
of the Legomen, and seeing exactly how they
reacted.
He had another D-Class build a commercial
airliner out of normal, non-anomalous Lego
bricks, and place it just to the side of the
Lego community.
Over the following three hour period, Dr.
Arch observed the Legomen engaging in some
truly remarkable behavior.
Upon noticing the plane, the Legomen began
to form a plan.
They first procured the necessary equipment
from the SCP-387 tub, and headed over to the
plane for a hard day’s work - in Legoman
time, at least.
With remarkable efficiency, the citizens of
the Lego community began forming a fully functional
airport around the plane.
Multiple runways, an air traffic control tower,
and even a mall and food court within the
airport itself.
Tiny Lego attendants tried to sell perfume
to uninterested Lego commuters and Lego TSA
agents frisked uncomfortable would-be Lego
passengers.
Its accuracy to the real-life airport experience
was truly brilliant.
But they didn’t stop there.
A tiny Lego fuel truck sped over to the plane,
and acted out the process of refueling it.
A Lego pilot and his Lego copilot climbed
into the plane, and it took off, literally
flying around the room without any kind of
logical propulsion system.
Dr. Arch was amazed.
And even then, they didn’t stop.
They continued to build more planes of various
makes and models, resulting in a sprawling
airport that, if you squinted, would look
just like the real thing.
From this, Dr. Arch concluded that 387 Legomen
had the ability to convert non-anomalous Lego
pieces into anomalous ones.
He proceeded to the next experiment.
For Experiment 387-b, Dr. Arch decided to
switch up the D-Classes and instead brought
in some of Lego’s more traditional target
audience: A group of 10-year-old children.
They began building some basic constructions
out of the pieces - your typical buildings,
people, and cars - but when they realized
that their creations were actually alive,
their tune immediately changed.
The kids spoke in hushed, excited tones about
a new plan, and then began putting it into
practice.
They built functional Transformers - and just
to be clear, it wasn’t electrical transformers
they crafted.
We’re talking Transformers as in actual
Optimus Prime and Megatron, an M1 Abrams tank,
and a number of different Lego weapons of
mass destruction.
Dr. Arch was mortified, realizing that he’d
apparently gathered up a team of budding childhood
supervillains, and had them removed from the
test chamber for amnestic treatment immediately.
However, the second the test chamber was vacated,
the kids’ creations came to life and entered
a state of all-out war.
It was an intense battle, lasting about an
hour, and left no Lego survivors, just a huge
mess around the room.
While this test was largely an embarrassment
for all involved, it did lead to some interesting
new data.
Not only was this anomaly Safe in the sense
that it didn’t pose a containment breach,
it was also Safe in the more colloquial sense
- there was no way these Lego bricks could
hurt you, unless you decided to eat them and
choked.
Don’t do that, by the way.
SCP-387 is unable to perform dangerous actions
if humans of any age are present in the vicinity.
And this arrangement goes both ways, too.
The Lego creations will be alive and, to some
extent, sentient, if played with peacefully.
However, if the human playing with them becomes
hostile, then they will immediately become
inanimate.
So play nice, folks.
Next came Experiment 387-c and Experiment
387-c-2, where Dr. Arch turned his attention
to the tub itself.
Since SCP-387 came into the Foundation’s
possession, the quantity of 387 blocks had
increased.
How is this possible, you’re probably wondering?
Dr. Arch and his team discovered an interesting
phenomenon: When some of SCP-387 is placed
back in the red tub, but the red tub isn’t
filled, then 387 will self-duplicate to fill
out the tub - much like the way a gas will
disperse to fill out any containment unit
it finds itself inside.
However, Dr. Arch also discovered some interesting
limitations.
There seemed to be no inherent anomalous qualities
to the red tub itself.
During one of the experiments, Dr. Arch half-filled
the red tub with non-anomalous Lego pieces,
and found that nothing changed.
Similarly, he performed another experiment
where he placed a single SCP-387 brick into
the box, and found there was no difference
when he came back.
Dr. Arch and his associates came to the conclusion
that the anomalous properties are confined
solely to the bricks themselves, but they
have a kind of symbiotic relationship with
the red tub, as they don’t replicate in
any other containment units.
In order to activate replication, the 387
must cover the entire bottom layer of the
tub.
Next came Experiment 387-d, where Dr. Arch
hoped to test the specific activation mechanisms
of SCP-387.
The Lego creations animated whether they were
being assembled by a child or an adult, so
it wasn’t an age-regulated anomaly.
The next experiment involved using a remotely-controlled
robotic arm to create a Lego construction,
to see if the mere act of construction itself
was enough to instigate 387’s primary anomalous
effect.
However, this didn’t turn out to be the
case.
The robotic-arm-assembled Lego construction
never came alive.
Dr. Arch’s next hypothesis was that perhaps
flesh was needed to activate SCP-387.
But how could he test using flesh, without
just having a normal human assemble the Lego
pieces?
Thankfully, the answer came to Dr. Arch by
total accident.
A few cells over, an anomaly trying to breach
containment had just killed a Foundation agent
trying to stand in its way.
While D-Classes cleaned up the mess, Dr. Arch
dragged the body over to where the 387 tests
were being conducted, and meticulously puppeteered
it’s arms and hands to put together more
387 Lego constructions.
But once again, it didn’t come to life.
Interesting.
Next hypothesis: Maybe it needed warmth to
activate?
In a move that proved unpopular with co-workers
just trying to eat their pre-packed sandwiches
in the Site-19 break room, Dr. Arch dragged
the dead Foundation agent’s body over toward
the room’s radiator, and leaned its arms
and hands over the top of it for twenty minutes,
before giving his newly-discovered puppeteering
skills another go.
But Once again, nothing happened.
Dr. Arch concluded that perhaps human psychic
energy, or maybe an active pulse, was what
caused 387 to activate.
If you’re waiting for the horrifying twist
- well, aside from the puppeteering of a dead
co-worker’s limbs - we’re pleased to tell
you that there just isn’t one this time.
SCP-387 serves no containment breach risk,
and no risk of harm to Foundation personnel.
In fact, playing with the living Lego has
led to an 87% increase in morale for Foundation
staff, so as long as you fill in the proper
forms and tidy up afterwards, you’re actually
allowed to play with the SCP-387 any time
you want.
After all, working for the SCP Foundation
is a stressful job, and really, we’re all
children at heart.
Oh, and there was one more experiment: Experiment
387-e: Where a Lego community was built using
SCP-387, and then a pile of Mega Bloks - Lego’s
most common imitator - was introduced into
the mix.
The Legomen of the community really weren’t
pleased by this.
While the actual details of what happened
have thankfully been expunged, the one clue
to what may have happened came from a note
left by Dr. Arch - that’s right, the puppeteer
guy.
His notes on that experiment were four simple
words: “OH NO NOT AGAIN!”
Now go check out “SCP-1007 - Mr. Life and
Mr. Death” and “SCP-5094 - Miss J's Whiz
Kidz Schoolhouse” for more fascinating safe-class
SCPs!